bonjour à tous et bienvenue à
bruxelles nous sommes comme toujours au
coeur du parlement européen pour ce
nouveau numéro de rappeler que d'eau et
dans cette émission nous irons congress
le gouvernement vous le savez à fermer
la télévision publique
alors s'agit-il d'une atteinte à la
démocratie ou d'une nécessaire
réforme la méthode en tout cas
à shopper toute l'europe
l'actualité c'est aussi le lancement
des négociations commerciales entre
l'europe et les etats-unis
dans ce dossier paris a tout fait pour
défendre son exception culturelle
barack obama pour les etats-unis
josé manuel barroso pour l'union
européenne
au milieu des la dirigeante du nord en
marge du g8 les représentants des deux
géants économiques ont donné le coup
d'envoi des négociations historique
entre les deux continents
objectif
créer la plus vaste zone de
libre-échange au monde
aujourd'hui avec le président obama
nous avons lancé cet accord très
important
le libre-échange et d'investissement
avec ce contrat et silence le fait est
que depuis deux mois le plus important
jamais mis en place
cet accord vise à baisser les droits de
douane entre bruxelles et washington
et en ouvrir des marchés aux
entreprises implantées des deux côtés
de l'atlantique de quoi changer la donne
face aux pays émergents et surtout face
à la chine voici le partenariat que
nous repèrent des etats-unis et le plus
riche au monde ils représentent presque
la moitié du pays d'aix mondial les
conclusions mille milliards de dollars
de hong kong par le service chaque
lecture
hier à la protection des données
personnelles en passant par les ogm
plus embarrassant le bras de fer qui
oppose paris et à bruxelles la france a
obtenu il extrait mis ce que le secteur
audiovisuel soit exclu du mandat des
négociations au nom de l'exception
culturelle que paris de défendre
de la toute puissance des plateformes
américaines comme google
dans une interview à un quotidien
anglophone josé manuel barroso a
dénoncé une attitude totalement
réactionnaire allusion indirecte aux
menaces françaises de veto répond
surprise de françois hollande
je ne peux pas croire que le président
de la commission européenne ait pu
tenir de tels propos sur la france
mais le commissaire européen karel de
gucht qui est chargée des négociations
assure que l'exclusion de l'audiovisuel
n'est que provisoire
la position française est loin de faire
l'unanimité eneurope
m
nous sommes cette semaine avec jean-luc
bennahmias second jour
aujourd'hui twitter européens vont
siéger ici au sein de l'alliance des
démocrates et des libéraux pour
l'europe c'est un téfécé a beaucoup
de choses notamment pour relations pour
130 coureurs
r américaines européennes entre
l'europe et l'amérique alors la france
s'est battu et continue de se battre
pour défendre l'exception culturelle ce
que c'est un combat français
wacom pointe dans le combat français
avait de quoi sur le sujet sur eux
cet accord union
européenne et etats-unis
au niveau du commerce international et d
marges
l'extérieur du commerce extérieur sera
le sujet central de mon point de vue des
prochaines élections européennes en
donc on a de quoi débattre il faut
même débattre en toute transparence
et pour l'instant ça n'est pas
transparent alors séparé actionnaires
cela progressiste tout ça n'est pas
transparent on a eu quelques mots
prime de résolution qu'on a voté au
parlement a strasbourg il ya quelques
jours
moi je me suis abstenu parce que
justement il a passé de transparence
c'est un débat fondamental comment vous
avez apprécié la petite phrase de
josé manuel barroso alors il dit que
c'était pas destiné
à la france mais on a bien compris le
message
dans un sens très mal ajustée
c'est le jeu
georges binz qui manque souvent aux
communes afin d'encourager autres par
rapport à toutes les politiques à
mener au niveau notamment de l'union
européenne cee
je sois vie semblait avoir fait quelques
progrès alors à cette phrase m'a aidé
et coton stupide
assez il met de l'huile sur le feu là
où il n'y en a vraiment pas besoin je
vous le dis
ce sera le débat central
en tout cas en france sera le débat
central sûres cet accord union
européenne etats-unis
pas la peine de mettre de l'huile sur le
feu
qu'est-ce qu'on veut défendre alors il
ya l'exception culturelle et ça ne
suffit pas à yale
tout ce qui est politique évidemment
audiovisuelle mais aussi de
l'agroalimentaire diane larocque
monstrueux
on fait par rapport aux services publics
a aussi commencé par rapport à
tout ce qui est écrit culture et on
sait bien que entre les notions
d'agriculture
en france on aura pesé et c'est pas la
même chose la commission européenne
dit redoutée des mesures de rétorsion
avant l'heure de la part des etats-unis
qui serait de fonder de dirais pas dans
ce cas
nous aussi on va négocier des
dérogations seraient pas déjà le cas
au menu des etats-unis ne protège pas
le nord industriel ne protège pas le
reconnaissent
l'offre faite par le roi
leur permet d'exister et bien sûr
qu'ils le font et moi je serai jeudi
pour l'union européenne nous ne le
faisons pas assez ce que vous dites
l'europe à être plus forts parce qu'il
ya quand même des risques
quel que soit son talent subissent
encore plus
l'invasion américaine non pour la
région américaine je pense que
l'europe subit déjà un retard
de beaucoup trop facilement là on se
donne
au niveau de l'europe et c'est très
bien des réglementations extrêmement
forte
réglementation ruée sur les produits
chimiques
des réglementations extrêmement forte
et où des directives sur la santé
sur l'environnement
mais tout ce qui vient de l'extérieur
on ne contrôle pas je n'ai que ça
n'est pas possible le ski est sorti
dernièrement sûres
les accords l'union européenne par
rapport aux panneaux photovoltaïques
par rapport à la chine
car depuis le début
de faire attention quand même à ce que
de ce que nous mettons nous au
règlement et en directive
pour eux de manière pas extrêmement
forte soit aussi le cas dans les
produits qui arrivent
d'où le continent autre etats-unis
chine brésil
voilà il s'agit non pas d'un
protectionnisme
ou sont-ce
or et actionnaire du terme il s'agit de
voir comment nous défendons
au niveau de l'union européenne notre
industrie dans le commerce et ce que
vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui l'union
européenne les institutions
européennes pour les moyens justement
de défendre ses intérêts
européens face à la toute puissance de
pays comme les etats-unis ou la chine
si elle s'en donner les moyens d entre
elles ne durent pas normalement et ça
va ça n'a pas paru non politique si je
ne vois pas
si certains ont été accordés
et dans ce cas-là c'est pas là d'un
débat franc cour européenne c'est un
débat de savoir
est-ce que
seule l'union européenne des calibres
marché
dans une concurrence faussée et non
libres n'ont pas libre et non faussée
mais l'averse
où est-ce que l'on se donne les moyens
politiques
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui c'est le
débat entre la france et l'allemagne
est une sombre
à ce niveau là où il ya des choses
vraiment hâte après avoir fouillé
pour progresser
d'autres grands pays comme l'italie
l'espagne la pologne doivent rentrer
aussi dense dans ce débat
je n'oublie personne année
de richesses et ses grands pays de se
mettre d'accord sur union politique
économique qui passe de mon point de
vue paris une fiscalité produire
progressivement commune dès le départ
et ouvriront en est malheureusement
très loin
tant qu'on se rassure un marché ouvert
à tout va
clairement les légumes choses sont mal
définis
et vous pensez que c'est une bonne chose
de plus l'union européenne signé avec
les etats-unis ce putsch ce traité de
libre-échange au fond qu'est-ce que
l'europe aille là-bas et gagner
l'usiné on se régalait
si l'europe l'union européenne tv
révèle d'abord aux politiques
économiques fiscales de manière
unifiée sûres les grands pays que je
viens de citer je pense que ce serait
avouer tout rondelle et gagner c'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui
c'est qu'aujourd'hui les déséquilibres
sont fortes gigantesque
les etats-unis
ce que je comprends bien monsieur obama
le lui dire défend son point de vue
ça n'empêche pas que les intérêts
américains et les intérêts
américains james douglas qui passe par
lui
face à certains protectionnisme il ne
s'en cache pas par rapport à leur
industrie
le rocker mans
e il n'y a pas d'autre solution que les
accords
de ce genre et si le son transparent et
si l'union européenne existe
réellement n est pas
uniquement un conglomérat d'état
nation aujourd'hui sept as
malheureusement souvent un conglomérat
de cassation
par jean-luc bennahmias
sino-européennes est en discussions
avec les etats-unis sur un autre sujet
très sensible la cybersurveillance le
renseignement
américains semblent réactualisé dans
les données de facebook au bout des
ailes pour surveiller l les
communications des citoyens américain
étrangers et même pas européen le
sujet a fait la chaîne de télévision
d'europe regardez
l'information a été dévoilée par le
quotidien britannique de gardien de but
en vertu d'une ordonnance de justice
crête l'opérateur téléphonique
verizon ne remettrai chaque jour à l'
agence nationale de sécurité des
renseignements sur des millions de
citoyens américains mais il faut quand
même prendre 6 5 le cadre politique
légal de la surveillance électronique
c'est un sujet très complexe mais
pourrait voir ce model
la collecte massive de données de
communication ils constituent une
violation inacceptable de la vie privée
et je ne puis dans ce dossier
depuis le séisme s'est produit
la matinée sa cible les communications
de n'importe qui elle traite les
données par défaut elle est recueillie
dans son système les filtres et les
stocks voilà justement cependant le
sprint il s'avère que ces méchantes se
gardant second tour de l'élection comme
autres - aux données du programme
pratique les prisonniers qui existe
depuis 2008 et qui collectent des
informations provenant de remake choqué
par de pages web l'historique de
recherche de données téléphoniques
étaient attendues tout
mais plus que le géant microsoft apple
ou google ou encore plus d'argent
beaucoup de surprises j'ai toujours agi
conformément à la loi répond facebook
assurant avoir rejeté de nombreuses
requêtes des autorités les
responsables du réseau social audi qui
compte six mois et avait reçu près de
10 mille demandes d'information
le chiffre que facebook met en
perspective avec son milliard
d'utilisateurs une façon de minimiser
l'ampleur du scandale
havas media create que les choses soient
claires ces droits fondamentaux des
citoyens
ne sont pas négociables
mais bien sûr ce que ce gouvernement
soit aussi se soucier de la sécurité
nationale
celui de la nécessité d'agir a
toujours fait partie des règles du jeu
l'international sans remonter jusqu à
mazara
bon aujourd'hui c'est avec les mets et
les moyens moderne et technologies
nouvelles elle et sa soeur
est-ce si surprenant que ça rame les
etats-unis nous écoute non
tout le monde peut tuer tout le monde
les hackers existait le tour de tout le
monde sait bien que la technologie peut
aider
sur les réseaux sociaux fait que tout
est absolument pas peut être
transparent
et voilà alors après est-ce qu'on se
donne les rénovations nécessaires pour
essayer de maîtriser tout cela
je pense que ça doit être le cas
de mai je pense que même si on met tout
ce qu'on peut
en forme pour le maîtriser tout cela il
aura toujours possibilité pour eux
tel gouvernement tel état ou telle note
puissance font trop
d'aller fouiller dans le réseau social
arias un projet de
des directives pour mieux protéger les
données personnelles c'est le
portefeuille de la vraie vie parce que
ça en est aujourd'hui
pendant des années a les moyens de
garantir la la protection la vie privée
des citoyens
anna miquel travail
je pense que le faire en toute
honnêteté mais ce que ça suffit je ne
crois pas
desclaud une réglementation c'est par
rapport à ça je ne crois pas non plus
parce que ce sont des réseaux
transparent
dans lesquels on peut rentrer si on est
un peu plus vieux
technologiquement malheureux
on peut y rentrer bon après qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait aux comores mois pour le
pôle principal état grave
on demande à un moment donné d'effacer
il faut cesser difficile que ça récent
states mais quand même d'effacer
c'est tout le problème de facebook %
par rapport notamment à nos adolescents
ou par rapport aux personnes qui au
milieu sur facebook un genre de choses
qui étaient
plus de leur vie privée que leur vie
publique
comment on fait
je crois que la bleue et il faut donc se
donner les directives nécessaires
ça ne changera pas au bout du compte de
toute façon un certain nombre de choses
stocker resteront stockés
or dans un monde traite
dématérialisés comme vous le dites
parce que l'état
pour tirer les premiers contreforts des
valeurs bouddhistes
je crois pas je crois pas répond avant
tout et tout ça
pourcentage ne l'aidait des systèmes
qui sont pour eux
digne de
de de champ de la science fiction dire
on est en plein dedans c'est plus que
son fils ne se déchire on est dedans la
science technologique
et de la technologie scientifique
totalement
le joli c simplement le droit à l'oubli
doit exister
cela soit la méthode utilisée par les
etats-unis
washington a accepté d'informer les
européens d'échanger des informations
avec le sur ce fameux programmant une
surveillance plus ferme votre collègue
à françoise castex maire a répondu
qu'il s'agissait d'une mascarade une
fois de plus
la commission européenne se félicite
les tissus des intérêts américain
dit-elle vous êtes du même avis
je ne dirais pas comme ça que je suis
venu de france ça c'est en raison de
cela
redoutant que nous ne sommes pas nos
capacités et d'avoir une union
européenne on le dit régulièrement
ceux qui soit unifiée en tout cas
collectivement il fit un certain nombre
de pays
bien sure chacun défend son petit bout
de gras l'etat-nation par etats-nations
pour sa première en ce moment et que
lille
mais les conseils européens
successivement ont du mal à se mettre
d'accord sur tout
quoi que ce soit ailleurs il veut rien
nous sommes
et quant à kankan est-ce qu'elle sera
castrats enfin d'accord quand est-ce que
cette union pourrait enfin voir le jour
alors même que m
la chine affirme sa toute puissance sur
la scène internationale et les
etats-unis renforcent à l'heure
il ne joue pas beaucoup
la france et l'allemagne les jeunesses
pas et je me différencie par le mur
comment dire
n'écoutez négative des différents
pays
la france tourne franche où les
français passeront de franchouillard
soit à l'exception culturelle
là c'est plus qu'utile mais je parle du
reste
l'allemagne parfois ce sont eux
ce proto poucet rieux le jour où la
france et l'allemagne décideront alors
donné d'avoir une fiscalité commune
dans la vie politique d'une commune des
politiques industrielles communes une
politique extérieure
et de défense commune rurale ce
jour-là
or en partant de la france et de
l'allemagne à savon doux pays italie
espagne portugal pologne
dion recruté au bon wagon veolia serait
d'accord avec vous et on aura une union
européenne réellement et les
fédéralistes
et politique qui permettra de
négocier le prix manière égale
tout à fait équitable et égal
avec 8 h d'une chine qui sont pas les
ennemis qui sont pour eux des gens qui
il faut bosser dans mon corps un jour
peut-être même si beaucoup plus
avisés daniel savard commenter
l'actualité elle pour nous on va parler
maintenant
de la grèce à françois beaudonnet
sort avec une députée
grec pour parler de l'incroyable
décision de fermer la télévision
publique
décision annulé en début de semaine
par le conseil d'état du pays
jérémy hartmann a passé de 48 ans
avec les salariés mobilisés au coeur
de la tourmente reportage
comme un petit air de woodstock
dans les chaudes soirées d'athènes
avec la coupure de la diffusion de la
télé publique laïque
ils étaient des milliers
jeunes
familles avec enfants
à se retrouver devant le siège de
l'afrique
dans une ambiance à la fois festive
et combative
pourquoi se priver
le gouvernement ap jeudi toujours les
chaînes publiques
avec une telle brutalité une telle
violence
ce ne sont pas des méthodes dignes
d'une démocratie
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on est là
pour essayer de sauver notre démocratie
un soutien
au 2600 fonctionnaires qui se retrouver
au chômage
sans préavis
dont près de 600 journalistes
et ça fait trois ans que je suis au
chômage je sais ce que ça veut dire
si nous sommes là aussi pour une chose
la solidarité la solidarité est encore
la solidarité personne ne devrait
rester laissés pour compte dans son
combat
la foule
compacte comme un bouclier humain autour
du bâtiment
de quoi redonner du baume au coeur aux
journalistes et techniciens qui se sont
relayés limitait jours à l'intérieur
à installer des radars embarqués
avec l'énergie du désespoir
ils ont continué à fournir des
programmes diffusés sur des sites
internet confidentielles
ces données proviennent sa déroute
on dort très peu on travaille 20 ans
par journée en direct si on donne des
interviews à la presse étrangère sans
savoir ce qu'on va devenir voilà
même si le texte lui-même mais je suis
aussi soulagé ça peut paraître
étonnant mais le climat était
tellement irrespirable ces dernières
semaines même s'ils ont travaillé
comme des fous pour 1200 heures par mois
et en plus on devait rendre des comptes
maintenant c'est devenu invivable
atmosphère pesante
ressentie par l'ensemble du personnel
car le werther c'est aussi un carré
deux orchestres symphoniques
violoncelliste française
il travaille depuis près de 20 ans
deux orchestres et les choeurs
qui disparaissent du jour au lendemain
c'est le meilleur club
c'était très sale
qui collaborent non pas seulement avec
nous mais aussi avec la presse nationale
régulièrement
certes les trois trucs comme ça
c'est pas une vitrine qui s'annonçait
on parle de la vie culturelle at-elle
ajouté la stratégie de l'écran noir
procéder je suis au camp pour certains
mal nécessaire pour d'autres
alors que l'union européenne la
deuxième mais le fmi réclame la
suppression de 2000 postes de
fonctionnaires avant fin juin
la porte-parole de nouvelle démocratie
le parti majoritaire de la coalition au
pouvoir
assumer parfaitement ce week-end encore
la décision du premier ministre antonis
samaras ce la cadette a été hélas
depuis une dizaine d'années
la façon de fonctionner de la télé
d'état italiens ce que la grèce est de
plus en plus prisés
à la face à toutes les tentatives de
réforme de l'audiovisuel public a été
choyé il ya quelques mois ça symbolise
la fin de la corruption et de l'opa
cité du grand
si le gouvernement s'est engagé à
assurer par un service minimum de la
formation
avant de rebâtir inde du visuel
publique plus transparent
le pays il restait privée d'information
pendant plusieurs jours
et pour de nombreux journalistes grecs
les arguments du gouvernement relevait
plutôt de la propagande d'état m en
dix de riposte
la rédaction de ce journal indépendant
a décidé de publier un numéro
exceptionnel
écrits imprimés presque bénévolement
cette parution spontanée a été
envoyée aux quatre coins de grèce avec
les moyens du bord et distribués sur
place auprès des manifestants athénien
d'abord l'audiovisuel public est
intégralement sans suite et on ne sait
pas s'il va revoir le jour
un beau soir de se retrouver à ne plus
savoir d'image à ne plus recevoir
toutes les infos de chaînes privées
les informations pas forcément fiables
au-delà des suppressions de postes de
fonctionnaires
la fermeture programmée de la
radio-télévision publique
c'était d'abord pour ces manifestants
un contre-pouvoir en moins
dans une démocratie en crise
tard cette nuit-là
ils reprenaient en choeur un chambley
matic de la résistance grecque
l'ultime façon de faire entendre leur
voix
un reportage athènes a signé je vais
mieux hartmann
alors nous sommes avec camille petit
matin bonjour
vous êtes députée européenne vous
êtes grecs la vice-présidente du du
parlement européen et vous êtes le
socialiste quand on vient de de voir ce
qui s'est passé
parce qu'il est toujours en train de
lire de se passer la télévision
entrée que même si
peut-être est-elle en train de de
rouvrir et ce que vous direz que c'est
la démocratie qui est en jeu dans votre
pays
absolument
à la sphère la démocratie qui est
elle pas en reste et ça c'est très
clair
pour que ce soit sur pour celle du res
qui pour 100 e
a été en europe
décidé à partager une partie du
gouvernement tripartite
un notamment parfois le parti
conservateur de la nouvelle démocratie
par la première ministre à samara cela
procéder au vote et pêchant prendre
tôt
ils ont offert une décision
sur la forme de décret
présidentielle est lancée
à midi la semaine dernière le monde
angela ahrendts
ils ont procédé à la fermeture de
de la télévision publique grecque net
tant que la procédure pêche encore
c'était clermont a pris la tête d'une
et latérales
cette année
ab démocratique du tout il n'y a pas eu
le débat parlementaire et que
il n'ya même pas d'une décision
dans ce sens du gouvernement
parmi les trois parties distinctes
forbes la ville gouvernement d'envoyer
sur lequel une décision
autoritaire voire d' autoritarisme son
public
vous connaissez la télévision grecque
parce que vous avez travaillé vous
étiez avec moi
vous les journalistes à la
correspondante à paris à paris
est-ce qu'il est vrai que la
télévision gratuite
irréformable
non je ne le crois pas je crois par
contre qu'il ya une nécessité absolue
pour réformer pauvre infrastructures et
à la télévision en plaques en
général et le secteur public le
connaît
mais j'adhère à marc caffet
d'abord
le le système politique
surtout le parquet
conservateur
qui bettencourt vire tout à coup
aujourd'hui que les télévisions
connectées
se trouve
or la situation des cristaux dont votre
arrêt portage
à ne pas encore
content comme télévision sur pas pu
être confirmée à kribi btp acceptera
moi je dis qu'il faut d'abord
pour les connaître à nos propres
responsabilité en tant que système
politique parce que c'est les systèmes
politiques traditionnelles en crète
en grèce at-il souri à damas aussi on
voyait aussi du ménage
face à l'irlande à l'éden
désaffectée depuis en italie et ses
terres
à l égard de la de la télévision
publique nrk d'entériner les décisions
pourquoi
pour ce faire les gens travaillaient
là-bas
elle qui s'était elle a donc pas halal
aaah aux gouvernements de chaque fois
tout ça
ils sont des choses qu'il faut changer
quel est l'objectif de du premier
ministre samaras c'est ce que c'est
vraiment
2 je changeais de télévision publique
grecque
il n'y arrivait pas parce que les
réformes se fassent faire
est-ce que ça va plus loin que ça
mais c'est un fait message envoyons-nous
en attendait
si vous faites pas ce qu'on veut voyez
qu'on abat des succès rock n'roll
s il voulait vraiment réformer
à la télévision connectée
il ya un projet de réforme qui est
très concret préc
elle devrait prévoir la demande
pour cent dans son tiroir fin
m
et le pire c'est le projet a été
lui-même en tant que chef de
l'opposition grecque
ap combattez très fortement
un roman qui est qu'il est là et
qu'elle sert
le projet a été présenté c'était la
période du gouvernement papa dimanche
et c'était les ministres
montier-la-celle propres
qui a procédé à la clôture ce moment
il aurait pu
pour cent ayant tapé et le piémontais
ses projets à qui parler
clermont des réductions
dur
plus de détails du sud at-elle affirmé
elle étape par étape
est-ce que parce que peu c'est vraiment
le gouvernement qui est responsable de
cette fermeture
où est ce que c'est la troïka
moi je crois qu'il ya longtemps mais
maintenant le responsable militaire
d'abord à
pagesjaunes
je fais confiance à c'est ce que les
institutions et la commission
européenne sur ton disque
ctl une décision automne membres du
gouvernement grec c'était une décision
pas même du gouvernement cela fait
partie du gouvernement
mais de l'autre côté
je crois que cette décision été
forcé une certaine façon
tarbes 2 % sous la
après six ans
dès l'achèvement
le turn
et du programme des morceaux nobles bois
d'orme cet art s étaient rares
il ya eu elle a droit à la retraite
après à l'engagement
pour preuve deux
mais une sortie
du secteur public et que jusqu'à la fin
du mois de juin
ils n'ont pas pu malheureusement mettre
en place
projet évaluations et des réductions
crédible cette contrée
donc nous arrivons au bout
pour 100 e de
de la fin du mois de juin sans avoir ces
projets a placé sans procéder à cette
récession autoritaire et faire tomber
la télévision publique pour pouvoir
donner à troïka c'est ce qu'il voulait
les deux années
pour s'en apercevoir c'est pas la
troïka qui en retombées les mises en
examen dans la soirée pour les
voyageurs
vous êtes une députée européenne
est-ce que vous avez été satisfaite
par heure
la réaction des autorités européennes
par exemple commission européenne opel
qui est dit
mais effectivement c'est une décision
du gouvernement c'est pas nous qui avons
demandé qu'il permette non je ne vais
pas jeter pas satisfaites
de la réaction des institutions a
surtout de la commission parce que
j'étais c'est très satisfaite de la
l action du président du parlement
européen mais s'il échoue ce qui est
envoyé à la traîne socialiste
tequila est socialiste mais qui la rend
les situent sur l'esl actuellement
et qui l'a envoyé à la trappe après
un mini-sommet éclair
en lui demandant de reconsidérer son
effigie en clair la commission d'appel
avec un tel prêt à dégainer
c'était très content de la réaction
des collègues de bédiala européen et
depuis ces attaques capitale n'entamant
pour cela
france
et c'est ce que je suis et moi-même
mère un parrain la plénière
%
a strasbourg %
à la semaine passée
c'est clair il s'agit à mon avis
et des taux les rays un tel déficit est
une violation de procédure
démocratique fondamental à des pays
membres de l'union européenne membres
mais la zone avant c'est pas un
problème grec mon avis c'est un
problème
à sète à problèmes r opel
et c'est un problème qui est lié à
mon avis
avec la façon qu'on a à gérer
la crise de la zone euro jusqu'à
présent on doit repartir pour
comprendre que ce que vous pensez que
justement il valide pour y avoir un
impact il ya des élections
par exemple européenne ce que ça peut
avoir un impact ce qui s'est passé que
les télévisions grecques qu'est-ce que
ça peut avoir un impact sur les
élections européennes et par tournera
pas est-ce que par exemple
les citoyens européens ne serait pas en
train de se disculper c'était depuis la
mort cette europe-là n'est pas si vieux
démocratique et pourrait être
en tout cas on a déjà des séminaires
presse alertant
auteur c'est le plus bas en suivant
l'eurobaromètre
on voit très clairement qu'une
majorité de citoyens ont d'eux-mêmes
presque partout eneurope
% n est plus de confiance euros est issu
en mai
pas seulement en effet de serre
j'ai dernièrement projet européen
le projet européen a perdu 100
sans gloire sa valeur qu'elles font
pourra convaincre
les citoyens qu'elle leur emploi cette
pauvre avec elle avant pâques
ça vaut la peine
pour faire cela
il faut que les décisions prises et
alessia la tarentaise
face à un signe clair de citoyens
comprendre que leur % d'intérêts
% en considération
donc ça va aider le coût de la crise
c'est vrai il faut pas que les citoyens
n'en comptera l'assument
la partie principale la démocratie et
la démocratie c'est à son ancienne on
peut pas procéder à faire des
réformes comme celles exigeante
5% respecter la loi et l'esprit dans les
urnes
peut-être de sète
chris arel euros alors ça sera donc que
pour l'année prochaine lors des
élections
européenne anni podimata merci beaucoup
de noirs
accepter notre invitation le sait la
frappe de de roquettes dont on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
avec la tête libérée d'ici là bonne
suite de programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires